“You darn kids with your e-pads and your
i-books!
In my day words were on dead trees and they
didn’t keep us up all night!”
Calm down angry grandpa I just made up, the
right e-reader will still let you get to bed
by 6 pm.
Hello bibliophiles, Julian here for DNews.
You’ve probably seen some stories recently
warning you that your e-reader is plotting
to give you insomnia and maybe cancer.
These articles are stemming from a recent
study published December 22nd in the Proceedings
of the National Academy of Sciences.
In the study 12 subjects each read books either
in paper form or an ipad for 4 hours a night,
5 nights in a row.
The next week they would switch to the other
format and spend another 5 nights reading
for 4 hours before bed.
Talk about a great excuse to re-read the Harry
Potter series.
The study found that those who read on the
newfangled ipads took longer to fall asleep,
spent less time in REM, and woke up feeling
more tired.
The hypothesis is the short-wavelength or
blue light from the ipad inhibited the release
of melatonin in the subjects, and this is
all based on solid science.
Melatonin is a hormone synthesized from the
amino acid tryptophan and it makes you feel
sleepy.
If you’re American you’re probably familiar
with the myth that thanksgiving turkey makes
you sleepy because of the tryptophan.
Let’s put that rumor to bed right now, because
turkey actually has slightly less tryptophan
than chicken.
Anyway, an enzyme with a really long name
I can’t pronounce so we’ll call it AANAT
is key for turning tryptophan into melatonin.
And as it turns out, AANAT’s gene responds
directly to light.
Given recent evidence of a link between melatonin
suppression and increased risk of breast cancer,
colorectal cancer, and prostate cancer, the
researchers of this study warn that using
an e-reader like an ipad before bed could
have bigger impacts than grogginess the next
day.
But before everyone freaks out and sets their
kindles on fire, there is an important nuance
that David Meyer of Gigaom points out; this
study only uses an ipad, at full brightness.
It doesn’t examine other e-readers like
my ancient kindle that still needs a reading
lamp, or newer devices that are front-lit
like the Kindle Paperwite or the Nook GlowLight.
We don’t know if these other ebooks are
better, but it’s not fair to lump them all
together because they don’t work the same.
The study didn’t dial down the backlight
of the ipads either, so it’s possible that
dimming them down will allow more melatonin
to be released.
As we love to say here on DNews, more research
is needed.
Of course if you notice you’ve been having
trouble sleeping after reading off your tablet,
maybe try one of the other methods or tone
the brightness down a little.
If you’re still having trouble, try reading
your school’s required books.
Those always knocked me right out.
Of course an e-book will always be missing
something we just love about their paper predecessors;
that old book smell.
Trace explains why we like that over here.
Have you guys had trouble sleeping after using
a dedicated ebook?
Or have you had trouble retaining information
when you didn’t with regular books?
Let us know in the comments and I’ll see
you next time on DNews.